first let me start with congratulations
thank you
um I definitely want to know what is the
secret for uh flying a dragon uh making
a movie when you're flying a dragon the
secret is trusting your safety belt
that is the first and then you too can
fly a dragon there's also caution
warnings um you know what you gotta
trust the team you're working with and
you know they they did have this
mechanism for the first time and it
really worked out for the best because
you needed a dragon to defeat this is
Emily ultimately and unfortunately your
sisters don't come along for the ride
sorry sorry so Calypso has to has to
call on Laden to help her out because
she is Raging at that point it's true
she's pissed you're pretty pissed at
that point I definitely want to know
though before you started filming did
you watch any Game of Thrones just to
see the way they did it or you sort of
like were doing their own thing you know
what I could never compete with the Game
of Thrones so I didn't the God yeah he
calls me please at one point the
goddesses are just different we're from
the different worlds we're not Zeitgeist
enough to know about the Game of Thrones
but I did I'm a big fan of the show and
House of dragons and and obviously that
team is fantastic but
I mean those are very different my
dragon is made out of wood
so very different
so one thing I want to ask both of you
is that Zach unlike most sets which can
be a little bit
um uh you know um run a certain way Zach
likes to play music yeah before scenes
and which is between yeah always yeah
right so I'm curious what was it like
with Zach and also um uh because it's
really a different energy when you're
playing music like that on set yeah um
and I'm just curious if there were any
sing-alongs or what all tons yeah
there's a lot of dance-a-thons yeah we
danced a lot on that there's a lot of
along to keep us awake and happy and I
was happy it was like everyone I think
his his mix is always on everyone knows
the songs everyone's
he's he really just lets Spotify go he
just lets it it is oh very smart because
I was like this is a great mix and um no
yeah I feel like I feel like now I
associate certain songs with with that
that summer yeah like that shooting kiss
me more by Doja cat and sizza and also
that one song that's like sometimes all
I think about is you late nights if he
used to play that all the time
yeah it was on like a repeat yeah big
boom box too this one of the things I
think David does so well is he's able to
manage the humor with like the darkness
like it's violent at times but it's also
like a family movie yeah he does it's
very unique tone can you sort of talk
about that aspect of the film and how
David it's like a unique he's very
unique with this yeah David has an
incredible sense of humor yeah and he
doesn't always show it outwardly but in
his work you can see that and he's got
such an imagination and he does a lot of
like horror yeah so I think the
combination is makes a great mix and
Shazam you know you don't want to just
keep it just for this one you know group
of people and he sort of opened it up in
the sequel to make it uh I guess for a
broader audience I mean that that's
Henry Gayden as well but also you know
he can see that he knows what he wants
when he's directing yeah and David
really reminds me of Just Like Old
School amblin Stevensville work stuff
where it really is like familial issues
in relation ends mixed in with these
otherworldly Fantastical settings and so
the fact that he's able to just kind of
effortlessly bring unicorns and Dragons
into a kid who's scared of Aging out of
the Foster system it's pretty amazing
and it doesn't seem like it should make
sense but it does and and that's the
that's the magic of David Sandberg Pony
Smash and also like making comedy from
awkwardness of people
and they're trying to find their way and
I really get such an accurate depiction
of a like Freddy in particular such an
accurate teenage depiction and that
comes from Jack and the and like there's
nobody like into it but it really is
it's written so well and then I think
it's something that everybody loves
everybody can relate to there's
something for everybody in in our movies
I agree on that note I gotta go I'm just
gonna say good luck with the rest of
your speed dating thank you thanks Steve